.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
In der Schweiz redet man nicht
übers Gewicht, Alter und Geld.
Acht von zehn Frauen sagen im Alter,
sie bereuen es,
sich nicht um ihre Finanzen
gekümmert zu haben.
Ich bin klassisch
in die Falle getappt.
Bei sämtlichen Themen. Das stimmt.
Es ist schwierig,
eine Frau zu finden,
die nach einer Trennung vor
der Kamera über Geldsorgen spricht.
Claudia D. will anonym bleiben.
Das Thema ist schambehaftet.
Aber ihre Geschichte ist typisch.
Sie ist Mutter von drei Kindern.
Das jüngste ist zwölf Jahre alt.
Sie hat sich vor acht Jahren
von ihrem Mann getrennt.
Eine traumatische Erfahrung -
auch in finanzieller Hinsicht.
Ich war eigentlich voll abhängig.
Ich arbeitete zu 20 %. Ansonsten ...
... kam das Geld von ihm.
Er sperrte beim Auszug
gleich sämtliche Konten.
Ich hatte keinen Zugang
zu unseren gemeinsamen Konten mehr.
Ich kam in der ersten Zeit
eigentlich durch die Unterstützung
meiner Familie
plus guter Freunde über die Runden.
Wenn die Kinder Schuhe
oder eine neue Jacke brauchten,
musste ich ausrechnen,
wie weit das Geld noch reichte ...
... und wie viel Geld ich
bis Ende Monat noch brauchte.
Teilweise waren es 8 Fr. pro Tag,
die ich mir einteilen musste ...
... damit wir Essen
auf dem Tisch hatten.
Claudia D.
hat sofort nach der Trennung
ihr Arbeitspensum auf 50 % erhöht.
Damit verdient sie
3'500 Fr. im Monat.
Das Scheidungsverfahren
läuft seit sechs Jahren.
Bei ihm war es nie das Finanzielle,
dass er nicht zahlen konnte.
Er hat einen sehr guten Lohn.
Für ihn war eigentlich immer ...
Er war überzeugt,
dass ich zu ihm zurückkehren würde,
sollte er nicht bezahlen.
Die Tatsache, dass er nicht zahlte,
was in den letzten Jahren Alltag
war, trieb mich in die Verschuldung.
Zusammen mit den Anwaltskosten
hat sich in den acht Jahren
seit der Trennung
ein Schuldenberg von 75'000 Fr.
angehäuft.
Nicht alle Frauen
begeben sich in der Beziehung
in eine solch grosse,
finanzielle Abhängigkeit.
* Sanfte Musik, ein Baby weint. *
Corinne und Yanick Brecher
sind ein typisches junges Elternpaar.
Aber
im Gegensatz zu 70 % aller Familien
kümmert sie sich zu Hause ums Geld.
Beide arbeiten.
Yanick ist Goalie beim FC Zürich.
Und Corinne arbeitet zu 60 %
selbstständig als Finanzberaterin.
Willst du noch etwas Salat?
- Nein.
Ich glaube, das war in
den letzten Jahren immer klassisch:
Der Mann brachte das Geld nach Hause
und kümmerte sich um die Finanzen.
Aber ich glaube: Mit all den
Veränderungen in den letzten Jahren
ist es logisch, dass sich
auch die Frauen mehr darum kümmern
und das auch extrem wichtig ist.
Ich habe auch von Paaren gehört,
die voneinander nicht mal wissen,
wie viel der andere verdient.
Und so kannst du ja auch
keine Planung machen.
Du musst doch irgendwie
einen gemeinsamen Plan haben, oder?
Nicht nur einen Plan, wie man
die Kinderbetreuung aufteilt,
sondern auch,
wie man es finanziell macht.
Corinne und Yanick Brecher haben
immer offen über Geld gesprochen
und ihre Finanzen
bei der Heirat zusammengelegt.
Wir haben ein Familienkonto,
auf das
alle Einnahmen einbezahlt werden.
Von diesem
gehen auch alle Ausgaben weg.
Sie kann gleich viel Geld brauchen
wie ich auch.
Klar: Grössere Investitionen
sprechen wir miteinander ab.
Aber es ist nicht so,
dass sie eine Haushaltskasse hätte,
nur weil sie Mutter ist.
Überhaupt nicht.
Und klar:
Wir haben auch immer vorgesorgt.
Wir haben beide immer
in die dritte Säule eingezahlt,
die natürlich sehr wichtig ist.
Komplett.
Die PK
war bei ihr bisher noch kein Thema,
weil sie immer noch angestellt war
und eine sehr gute PK hatte.
Als Tochter Louisa geboren wurde, hat
sich Corinne selbstständig gemacht.
Das hat auch Konsequenzen
für ihre Altersvorsorge.
Das sind eben
auch die kritischen Zahlen,
die mit der Pensionskasse kommen.
Also man muss diese 21'000 Fr.
und noch mehr verdienen,
damit man überhaupt eine PK hat.
Dann ist es
bei der dritten Säule so:
Wenn man es herunterrechnet,
kann ich mit meinem 60-%-Pensum
die über 6'800 Fr. pro Jahr
nicht einzahlen.
Es ist für mich alleine
einfach nicht möglich.
Darum füllt er mir das auf.
Das haben wir so vereinbart.
Ich sage jetzt mal:
Im Scheidungsfall ist es 50:50.
Ähm ... Ja, also ...
Das ist mir bewusst.
Solange ich wenig arbeite oder
einfach in einem reduzierten Pensum,
muss man bei der PK
und bei der dritten Säule
ein Augenmerk darauf haben.
Die wenigsten wissen so gut Bescheid
wie Corinne und Yanick.
Das heutige Sozialversicherungsrecht
ist darauf ausgerichtet,
dass die Familie zusammenbleibt.
Kommt es zur Trennung,
haben die Frauen
oft das finanzielle Nachsehen,
wenn sie sich vorher
nicht darum gekümmert haben.
Barbara Anliker
ist seit sieben Jahren geschieden.
Ihre Kinder
sind zehn und 13 Jahre alt.
Die Kinderbetreuung teilen sich
ihr Ex-Mann und sie hälftig auf.
Sie wohnt in einer 3-Zimmer-Wohnung
für 1'500 Fr.
und arbeitet zu 50 %
als Handarbeitslehrerin.
Also ich bekomme 4'000 Fr.
Darin sind noch Kinderzulagen
von 450 Fr. enthalten.
Wir kommen mit 3'500 Fr. durch.
Was ich brauche, kaufe ich
wann immer möglich auf Ricardo.
Oder Tutti oder so.
Also gebrauchte Sachen.
Oder ich lasse mir Sachen schenken -
von Leuten,
die diese nicht mehr brauchen.
Ich verschenke auch selber viel.
Es gibt einen regen Austausch.
Ich kaufe seit Jahren
schon keine Kleider mehr.
Freundinnen und ich
tauschen untereinander die Kleider.
Für die Kinder musste ich bisher
auch nie gross Kleider kaufen.
Wir haben dort vorne
eine Kinderkleiderbörse: KiWi.
Dadurch brauchen wir gar nicht viel.
Ich benutze keine Kosmetik.
Es geht einfach. Es ist
auch nicht knapp. Überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe nie das Gefühl,
mich einschränken zu müssen.
Die Kosten für die Kinder übernehmen
sie und ihr Ex-Mann hälftig.
Unterhaltskosten an sie
zahlt er nicht.
Ich habe etwas mehr gemacht,
aber das liegt auch daran,
dass er auch selbstständig ist -
oder besser: Er ist selbstständig.
Er hat mit 80 % etwa gleich
viel verdient wie ich mit 50 %.
So ging das tipptopp auf.
Und er hat immer schon,
von Anfang an,
die Kinder für einen Tag
pro Woche betreut. Immer.
Selbstverantwortung war
der 51-Jährigen schon immer wichtig.
Geld hingegen nicht.
Es gab auch Momente,
in denen ich dachte:
"Jetzt ist es fertig.
Jetzt habe ich nichts mehr."
"Ich muss darauf achten,
dass etwas reinkommt."
Aber das brauchte es auch, denn
ich merkte: "Nein, es kommt immer."
Barbara Anliker und Claudia D.:
zwei Frauen, zwei verschiedene
Situationen, eine Gemeinsamkeit.
Beide haben sich, wie viele Frauen,
nie für ihre Finanzen interessiert.
Ganz anders Corinne Brecher.
Als ich sie vor sechs Monaten
zum ersten Mal treffe,
ist sie schwanger
mit ihrem zweiten Kind.
Hallo, Schatz!
Hallo!
- Hallo, hallo, hallo!
Geht es dir gut?
- Wunderbar, und dir?
Auch, danke.
- Sehr gut. Schön.
In ihrem Elternhaus wurde immer
ganz offen über Geld gesprochen.
Das hat ihr Interesse
schon früh geweckt.
Von Andreas Seite
war man sehr offen.
Es war eine Unternehmerfamilie.
Man wusste, was läuft.
Und bei mir war es so:
Ich verlor mit 17 meinen Vater.
Innerhalb von 3 Std.
war er tot und weg.
Man wusste,
was vorhanden ist und was nicht.
Die Bank sperrte die Konten.
Man hatte einfach
keinen Zugang zum Geld.
Das ist auch heute noch so.
Und darum glaube ich,
dass es besser ist,
wenn man darüber diskutiert und
sich an den Möglichkeiten beteiligt,
die man heute hat.
Corinne wurde Betriebsökonomin
und berät heute explizit Frauen
in Finanzangelegenheiten.
Mit Webinaren, Blogs
und einer Kolumne in der "Annabelle"
will sie erreichen,
dass v.a. auch junge Frauen
sich aktiv um ihr Geld kümmern.
* Ruhige Musik *
Sie besucht ihre Freundin Lea.
Ihr hilft sie
im Moment bei der Finanzplanung.
Hallo!
- Hallo!
Schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Hallo!
- Hallo! Alles klar?
Alles klar. Komm, wir gehen rein.
Danke vielmals.
- Sehr gerne.
Was ist eigentlich mit der Vorsorge?
Hast du mal etwas gemacht? Das,
was wir das letzte Mal besprachen.
Das letzte Mal hatten wir die
Diskussion ... Du hattest nichts.
Nein, da hatte ich noch nichts.
Ich habe mal
meine Strategie geändert.
Aha!
- Ja.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Ich habe diese Global-100-Strategie
gemacht.
Ah. Mit den Aktien?
- Genau.
Aber du hast
nicht erst 100 % Aktien genommen?
Nein,
ich hatte das Global-60-gemacht.
Über die letzten 15 Jahre
hat sich Anlegen tatsächlich gelohnt.
Verglichen mit Geld auf dem Konto
hat sich Geld,
angelegt in Fonds mit 100 %
Aktienanteil, um 260 % vermehrt.
Frauen bevorzugen immer noch
ein Sparkonto gegenüber einem Depot.
Äh ... Sie legen es einfach
viel weniger oft an als die Männer.
Und ich meine:
Der Unterschied ist massiv.
Ich denke, es ist ganz klar ...
... auch etwas, was in der Schweiz
gesellschaftlich bedingt ist,
Bei sieben von zehn Paaren
ist es der Mann,
der sich um die Finanzen kümmert.
Ähm ... Das ist schade.
Das ist ganz klar.
Ähm ...
Aber ich verstehe auch die Frauen.
Sie müssen sich sonst schon
um relativ viele Sachen kümmern.
Sie sagen oft: "Ich kümmere mich
nicht auch noch um die Finanzen."
(Originalton)
Der richtige Partner unterstützt
Sie, damit Sie Ihr Ziel erreichen.
Auch in der Werbung wurden und werden
v.a. immer noch Männer angesprochen,
wenn es ums Geldanlegen geht.
(Originalton) Und er begleitet Sie
bei all Ihren Entscheidungen.
So wie die Raiffeisenbank, wenn es
um Ihre finanzielle Vorsorge geht.
Wir kennen unsere Kunden und
können sie persönlich beraten.
Lea hat sich kürzlich verlobt
und ist mit ihrem Partner
in diese Wohnung gezogen.
Da hätten wir unser Schlafzimmer.
- Megacool mit diesem Dach!
Ja, es ist toll.
- Wirklich schön!
Und es ist total ruhig.
So schön!
Oh, da hast du noch ein Gärtchen.
Falls es Nachwuchs geben sollte:
Wäre das hier das Kinderzimmer?
Habt ihr euch das überlegt?
Na ja, also ... Es sieht
jetzt noch nicht danach aus.
Aber wenn es so weit wäre, wäre das
sicher eine Möglichkeit, ja.
Habt ihr euch auch überlegt,
wie ihr es macht, wenn ihr heiratet?
Heute ist das Konkubinat
z.T. noch beliebt.
Mhm.
- Habt ihr darüber geredet?
Ja ... ähm ...
Aber wir haben ja vor,
eine Familie zu planen.
Mhm.
Es macht schon Sinn, dass wir
heiraten, wenn wir Kinder wollen.
Mhm.
Und ... ähm ...
- Meinst du aus finanzieller Sicht?
Ja.
- Oder allgemein?
Oder auch wegen der Absicherung.
- Finanziell auf jeden Fall.
Vom Konkubinat
rät Corinne kategorisch ab.
Solange Lea verheiratet bleibt,
ist sie tatsächlich abgesichert.
Trennt sie sich,
sieht es aber anders aus.
Gerade, wenn es früh
zu einer Scheidung kommt
und die Kinder noch klein sind,
kannst du
auch nicht mehr voll arbeiten.
Mhm.
Dann hast du ein Problem mit
der Pensionskasse und der Vorsorge.
Mhm.
Dann muss auch klar sein,
dass ... äh ...
dein Mann dir finanziell auch hilft.
- Mhm.
Ja.
Langfristig geht sonst ...
Der Gap ist nachher riesig.
Mhm.
- Das holst du nicht mehr auf.
Du hast Kinder und
reduzierst nachher auf 40 oder 60 %.
Dann hast du
eine Rentenlücke von 42 %.
Das macht dann so viel aus?
- Das ist heftig, oder?
42 %, die dir einfach fehlen.
- Ja.
42 % hätte Lea weniger
alleine bei der Pensionskasse.
Über die ganze Vorsorge gesehen,
also mit der AHV, wären es 37 %.
So viel Altersvorsorge haben Frauen
im Schnitt weniger zur Verfügung,
sofern sie nicht von einem Mann
zusätzlich unterstützt werden.
Ich habe zuerst angefangen,
die Jungen zu motivieren.
In der Beratung hatte ich
dann aber Frauen ab 45 Jahren.
Dort tauchten Probleme auf,
sprich die Altersvorsorge,
über die man sich Gedanken macht.
In 20 Jahren merkt man:
Die Lücke wird grösser.
Und dann natürlich Scheidung,
Todesfall ... all diese Szenarien.
Dann komme ich einfach rein, wenn
das Haus sozusagen schon brennt.
Das ist schade.
Acht von zehn Frauen sagen im Alter,
sie bereuen es,
dass sie sich nicht mehr
um ihre Finanzen gekümmert haben.
Das müsse sich dringend ändern,
findet Helena Trachsel.
Sie ist Gleichstellungsbeauftragte
des Kantons Zürich
und führt regelmässig an Schulen
und Ausbildungsstätten
Workshops für junge Frauen durch.
Heute an der Uni Zürich.
Ganz, ganz herzlich willkommen
im Namen der Fachstelle.
Wir machen
diese Workshops regelmässig.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, warum?
Warum seid ihr hier? Ganz kurz?
Ganz mutig sein!
Finanzplanung in der Zukunft.
Wenn man Teilzeit arbeitet,
kann man in eine Lücke fallen.
Finanzkenntnisse
sind für euch Frauen ein Muss.
Ihr habt es vorhin angesprochen:
Frauen und Finanzen sind ein Muss.
Ihr müsst euch
unbedingt kundig machen,
was das in Sachen Lohn
und Sozialversicherungen bedeutet.
Ihr müsst schauen, was das eigene
BVG und die dritte Säule heissen.
Ihr müsst auch steuertechnisch
schauen, was es heisst.
Genauso könnt ihr schauen,
wenn ihr mal gut verdient:
Macht ihr Investments
in Nachhaltigkeit,
in nachhaltige Fonds?
Behaltet
die ganze Palette von Finanz-
und Sozialversicherungsprodukten
auf dem Radar! Unbedingt.
Wir haben schon vor einigen Jahren
Studien durchgeführt,
die schauen,
welches Teilzeitmodell sich rechnet.
60 und 80 %
ist ein sehr gutes Modell.
Aber wirklich rechnet sich
das Modell 70 und 70 %.
Wenn ihr eine Chance habt,
mit eurem Partner
oder eurer Partnerin auszuhandeln,
wie viel ihr arbeiten wollt,
raten wir: 70 und 70.
Dann seid ihr sozialversichert
wie auch steuertechnisch ...
Ihr müsst dieses Wissen unbedingt
Kolleginnen und Kollegen weitergeben
und das auch verhandeln.
Seid romantisch verliebt!
Es ist wunderschön, über beide Ohren
verliebt zu sein und zu denken:
"Die Person an meiner Seite
ist die richtige."
Gerade so wichtig ist es,
in dem Moment zu sagen:
"Hey, wenn wir das machen,
dann zusammen."
Und wenn die männlichen Partner
nicht Ja sagen
und es sich überlegen,
ob es richtig ist, Kinder zu haben,
überlegt es euch und sagt:
"Dann weiss ich nicht,
ob ich das mit dir will."
"Ich will drin bleiben."
Gesamtgesellschaftlich
bewegt sich nichts,
wenn sich die Männer nicht mehr
engagieren können und Druck machen.
Augen auf bei der Partnerwahl:
Rund 70 und 70 arbeiten ist also
das Mantra von Helena Trachsel.
Wie sehen denn das die Studierenden?
Ich habe auch schon darüber
gesprochen. Für mich ist klar ...
Ich habe fünf Jahre studiert
und will doktorieren.
Ich bleibe
dann nicht zu 100 % zu Hause.
Ich habe auch schon mit
anderen Leuten geredet, die finden:
"Karriere und Kinder - man muss
schon für beides Zeit haben."
Ähm ... Es ist schon ein
Spannungsfeld. Das merke ich auch.
Ich finde es schwierig zu sagen.
Ich komme eher aus
einem konservativen Familienmodell.
Meine Geschwister haben auch Kinder.
Sie arbeiten meist zu 30,
40 % und ihre Männer zu 100 %.
Ich möchte das nicht so,
aber gleichzeitig ...
Na ja, also ...
Meine Vorstellung war bisher,
60 % zu arbeiten.
Und für mich ist die Idee neu,
darüber zu verhandeln,
bevor man ein Kind bekommt.
Das ist ja
ein weiter Schritt in der Beziehung.
Aber ja, es ist sicher sinnvoll.
Unter diesen Akademikerinnen
ist der Wille gross,
weiter im Job zu bleiben
und Familienarbeit zu teilen.
Aber die Partner zu Teilzeitjobs
zu bewegen, ist schwierig.
Ich habe diese Diskussion
mit meinem Partner,
weil er
in der Wissenschaft bleiben möchte.
Es gibt
wenige Beispiele von Professorinnen,
die sich um die Kinder kümmern -
und Professoren noch weniger.
Meistens sind es die Frauen,
die sich um die Kinder kümmern.
Das kann ich mir
einfach nicht vorstellen.
Wir verhandeln tatsächlich noch.
Ich habe ihm klar gesagt:
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass ich mich zu 100 %
um Kinder und Haushalt kümmere.
Er möchte sich eigentlich
auch um die Kinder kümmern,
weiss aber nicht,
wie das einbaubar ist,
und sucht nach Beispielen.
Er schaut sich um, wie das
Kolleginnen und Kollegen machen.
Ich bin schon gewillt,
diese 70 und 70 zu verlangen,
weil ich es mir sonst
eigentlich nicht vorstellen kann.
Ich habe jetzt einen Partner,
der zu 100 % arbeitet.
Eigentlich sogar noch mehr.
Und
ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen,
unter diesen Voraussetzungen
Kinder mit ihm zu bekommen.
Solche Forderungen hat Claudia D. vor
dem Kinderkriegen nicht gestellt -
wie die meisten Frauen.
An die Schwierigkeiten,
die sich aus ihrer romantischen
Unbekümmertheit ergeben könnten,
hat sie nicht gedacht.
Diese schwierige Zeit,
also die ganze Trennungszeit,
hält seit acht Jahren an.
Mir sind meine Freunde wichtig
und auch die Erholung in der Natur.
Ich gehe oft im Wald spazieren
und achte darauf,
dass ich mir selber
etwas Gutes tun kann,
um Energie für die Arbeit,
den Alltag,
den ganzen Kampf
und die Kinder zu haben.
Wir haben eigentlich immer
zu wenig über Finanzen geredet.
Als wir heirateten,
arbeitete ich auch zu 80 %.
Ich hatte mein eigenes Geld.
Es reichte eigentlich für alles.
Damals überlegte sie sich nicht,
was wäre,
sollte
die Beziehung auseinandergehen.
Als wir heirateten,
wollte er eine Gütertrennung,
weil er von seiner Familie aus
mehr Geld hatte.
Dort gibt es viel Geld.
Es gibt Immobilien.
Da mir Geld nicht viel bedeutet,
war das für mich kein Problem,
kein Thema.
Es war für mich klar, dass ich
von seiner Familie kein Geld wollte.
Daher habe ich
für eine Gütertrennung eingewilligt.
Und dass er für dich
eine dritte Säule machen würde?
Auch nicht. Er machte für sich eine.
Aber dass er für mich auch eine
machen würde, war nie ein Thema.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich treffe Barbara Anliker wieder.
Sie versucht seit einiger Zeit,
mit Upcycling von Jeans
ihr eigenes Business aufzubauen.
Ihre Kollegin Olga Miler
hilft ihr dabei.
Es gäbe so viele Möglichkeiten.
Schau, der Rücken!
Ich habe etwas,
was zu den Farben passt.
Ich habe ein Inserat
im "A-Bulletin" gemacht.
Drei Leute meldeten sich.
Ich habe geschrieben, ich suche
einen Verkaufsprofi für Upcycling.
Es kommt schon.
- Es kommt schon.
Ich würde gerne davon leben.
Und ... ähm ... ja, genau.
Ganz alleine ist es schwierig.
Ich kann nicht nähen, gleichzeitig
die ganze Werbung machen und ...
Es braucht einfach zu viel Zeit.
Daher suchte ich jemanden,
der hilft.
Zuerst hatte ich jemanden,
der beim Nähen geholfen hätte,
aber das brauchte es nicht.
Der Ständer war voll.
Bis du die Saisonalität
herausgefunden hast, also sagst:
"Verkaufen wir im Frühling
oder im Winter mehr?",
ist auch eine Schwierigkeit
bei dem Ganzen.
Kaffee!
- Ja.
Wir gehen raus,
um einen Kaffee zu trinken.
Was könnten wir noch versuchen?
Wahrscheinlich
braucht es einen Instagram-Shot.
Olga Miler ist Finanzberaterin -
wie Corinne Brecher.
Auch sie ist selbstständig,
gibt Kurse für Frauen
und hat einen Geldblog auf Watson.
Ich dachte schon länger, dass das
mit Instagram eine gute Idee wäre.
Aber ich gehöre nicht zu denjenigen,
die das gut können.
Finanziell angewiesen auf dieses
Business ist Barbara Anliker nicht,
solange sie zu 50 % als
Handarbeitslehrerin angestellt ist.
Anders sieht es
nach ihrer Pensionierung aus.
Wie sieht es
mit deiner Altersvorsorge aus?
Äh ... ja, nicht so gut.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich
eine hohe AHV bekommen werde.
Ich hatte nie
eine Anstellung zu 100 %.
Mein ganzes Leben nicht.
Und die Pensionskasse?
Ähm ...
Da bekomme ich viel von der Schule.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie viel dort drauf ist.
Es interessiert mich auch nicht.
Ich bewundere deine Gelassenheit,
und auf der anderen Seite ...
Warum
interessiert es dich denn nicht?
Oder sage ich das jetzt falsch?
- Nein.
Um es zu verstehen und zu sagen:
"Wie viel AHV werde ich bekommen?"
"Wie ist das mit der Pensionskasse?"
Damit du verstehen würdest,
was auf dich zukommt.
Ich glaube, das versuche ich,
den Leuten ans Herz zu legen,
weil ich viele Leute treffe,
die sagen:
"Hätte ich das früher gewusst!"
- Mhm.
Ich weiss eigentlich, was passiert.
Ich weiss, dass ich
nicht viel Geld bekommen werde,
aber auch,
dass ich nicht viel brauche.
Ich habe immer mit wenig gelebt,
und mir ist es wohl so.
Und ich wüsste nicht,
warum ich im Alter müsste ...
Ich glaube, ein kleines Zimmer
in einem Haus am Waldrand ...
Das kostet nicht alle Welt.
Das reicht mir.
Warum soll ich mich
mein Leben lang abmühen,
um später Geld zu haben, wenn ich
nicht weiss, ob ich es brauche?
Lücken in der Altersvorsorge sind bei
geschiedenen Müttern oft ein Problem.
Jetzt will das Bundesgericht
bei Scheidungen
zudem die Unterhaltszahlungen
an die Frauen streichen.
Das neuste Urteil
hat viele Diskussionen ausgelöst.
Barbara Anliker allerdings
findet es völlig in Ordnung.
Ich wüsste nicht,
warum er mir etwas zahlen sollte.
Ich bin ja selbstständig.
Ich kann ja selber auf mich achten.
Warum soll die Frau
von ihm Geld bekommen?
Es sind ja einfach zwei Menschen.
Ich sehe es nicht.
Und wenn man sich die Kinderkosten
teilt, ist es ja fair.
Viele Frauen
sehen sich in der Opferrolle.
Sie haben ihren Beruf aufgegeben
und sich
sozusagen für die Kinder geopfert.
Und das ... Sie finden dann,
der Mann sei schuld.
Sie schieben ihm die Täterrolle zu.
Und das ist ... äh ...
ein Ort,
wo man sich nicht entfalten kann.
Man ist klein in dieser Opferrolle.
Sie ist etwas Kleines.
Deshalb wirst du handlungsunfähig.
Du kommst nicht vom Fleck.
Wenn du selbstständig oder dich ...
Wenn du
in die Selbstständigkeit gehst
und Eigenverantwortung für dich
und dein Leben übernimmst,
auch fürs Geld, aber auch
für alles rundherum, dann ...
Nur schon, wenn man das ausspricht,
merkt man, wie man Kraft bekommt,
in Schwung kommt und sich freut,
etwas zu machen.
Ja, ich denke, ein Teil von mir ist
total bei Barbara und ihrer Aussage.
Der andere Teil von mir
kann die Aufregung verstehen.
Wenn beide dieselbe Chance haben,
im Beruf Fuss zu fassen,
oder beide einen Beruf haben und
auch ihre Existenz tragen können,
wie du gesagt hast - absolut.
Völlig bei dir.
Aber wenn jemand in der Gemeinschaft
eine Rolle übernommen hat,
und diese besteht darin, den ganzen
Haushalt und die Kinder zu managen,
damit der andere im Beruf
vielleicht schneller vorwärtskommt,
mehr Karriere machen kann
und auch mehr Freiheiten hat,
ist das für mich
eine andere Ausgangslage.
Es ist schwierig, wenn dieser Mensch
von einem Tag auf den anderen sagt:
"So, jetzt musst du
für dich selber sorgen!"
Egal,
ob es der Mann oder die Frau ist.
Du kannst dich
als Haushaltsmanagerin
ja nicht
irgendwo anders einstellen lassen.
Ja.
Das Bundesgerichtsurteil
zwingt die Frauen
zur finanziellen Eigenverantwortung
und wird in manchen Familien
für Diskussionen sorgen.
Auch bei den Sozialversicherungen
werden die Frauen
weiterhin selbst schauen müssen.
Bei den anstehen Revisionen
versucht man zwar,
Mütter besser zu stellen.
Lösungen für eine Berücksichtigung
der Familienarbeit
sind aber keine in Sicht.
Olga Miler war 15 Jahre
in der Finanzindustrie tätig
und hat für die UBS
diverse Genderstudies gemacht.
Nun veranstaltet sie Finanzwebinare
speziell für Frauen.
Ich habe festgestellt, dass Frauen
den grössten Bedarf haben,
was Finanzbildung angeht,
würde ich mal sagen.
Viele Frauen haben Hemmungen,
über Geld zu reden.
Sie haben das Gefühl,
sie wüssten zu wenig darüber,
obwohl das von den Fakten her
vielleicht gar nicht so ist,
aber gefühlt.
Sie trauen sich deswegen auch nicht.
Und viele Frauen fühlen sich
auch ein bisschen ausgegrenzt.
Man geht zusammen zur Bank.
Und dort wird immer
nur mit einer Person gesprochen.
Das ist so, als würden Sie
zum Autohändler gehen,
und dieser
erklärt dem Mann den Motor im Detail
und Ihnen die Farbe des Autos.
Das fehlende Wissen ist eine Sache -
wenn man Geld hat.
Aber es gibt auch viele Menschen,
die Ende Monat
nichts beiseite legen können.
Ich glaube, da fand schon
eine grosse Demokratisierung statt -
durch all diese digitalen Tools,
die es gibt -,
dass auch Menschen mit sehr
wenig Geld Anlagen tätigen können.
Ein ETF-Share kostet 10 Fr.
Einen Fondssparplan können Sie
für knapp 50 Fr. pro Monat haben.
Mikrosparen
funktioniert mit Aufrunden.
Vor zehn Jahren war das noch anders.
Damals bekam man die tolle Beratung
und den Service erst,
wenn man ein gewisses Vermögen
zur Verfügung hatte.
Aber ich glaube,
heute kann jeder, der möchte,
die Ärmel hochkrempeln
und investieren,
wenn er das gern möchte.
Ohne Gewinngarantie natürlich.
Aber es ist im Moment die einzige
Möglichkeit, sein Geld anzulegen,
wenn man sich -
wie die meisten Menschen -
keine Immobilien leisten kann.
Dass Geldanlegen v.a.
für kleine Jungs wichtig ist,
wird in der Werbung klar suggeriert.
* Popmusik *
(Originalton)
Schön, wer mit dem Sparen wieder
neu beginnt und eine Bank sagt:
Eigentlich
fängt es beim Taschengeld-Gap an.
Es gibt Studien, dass kleine Mädchen
im gleichen Alter
weniger Taschengeld bekommen
als kleine Jungs.
Das zieht sich
natürlich über die Löhne
bis hin zu Nachteilen
bei den Lohnverhandlungen,
bei denen Frauen
einerseits anders verhandeln,
andererseits aber auch
anders wahrgenommen werden.
Dann zieht sich das natürlich durch
den ganzen finanziellen Lebenszyklus
bis hin zur Pensionierung.
Dieses Modell zeigt:
Während ein Mann,
wenn er die ganze Zeit
100 % arbeitet,
sein Vermögen von 1 Mio.
auf 6 Mio. Fr. steigern kann,
verliert die Frau
wegen geringerem Lohn,
Auszeit wegen Kindern, kleinerem
Pensum nach dem Wiedereinstieg
und fehlendem Investment
meistens Geld
und landet im Minus,
falls sie nicht verheiratet bleibt
und vom Geld ihres Ehemannes
profitieren kann.
Hallo zusammen.
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
Ich bin in
der Trennungs- bzw. Scheidungsphase
und weiss nicht, wie es weitergeht.
Obwohl ich für die Finanzen
und die Buchhaltung zuständig bin,
geht es jetzt um meine Buchhaltung,
um meine Finanzen.
Daher bin ich hier.
Ich will sehen, was ich
für meine Vorsorge machen muss.
Ich habe in der AHV massive Lücken.
Meine Vorsorge sieht allgemein
relativ miserabel aus.
Ich habe mal ausrechnen lassen,
dass ich im Alter
mit 1'000 Fr. durchkommen müsste.
Meine Frage ist: Wie mache ich das?
Welche Möglichkeiten habe ich?
In der Schweiz sind zweimal so viele
Frauen von Altersarmut betroffen
als Männer.
Investieren kann
nicht alles für euch reparieren.
Aber es kann
eine Minderung verschaffen.
Rahel Beutler ist auch
eine der Kursteilnehmerinnen.
Sie hat vor einem Jahr geheiratet.
Es hat mich bestärkt auf dem Weg,
den ich jetzt gehe.
Jetzt nehme ich es in die Hände. Ich
will es nicht so weit kommen lassen.
Obwohl ich schon über 30 bin
und es natürlich besser ist,
wenn man schon ganz früh beginnt,
bin ich noch in einem Alter,
in dem man
noch viel bewegen und machen kann.
Und ... ähm ... ja. Wenn ich es
nicht jetzt mache, wann dann?
Sie gehört zu den wenigen Frauen,
die vor der Heirat
mit ihrem Partner abgemacht haben,
wie es finanziell weitergehen soll,
wenn Kinder kommen.
Natürlich ist es nicht romantisch,
wenn man über solche Sachen
diskutieren muss.
Andererseits
ist es auch eine falsche Wahrheit,
wenn man in einer Beziehung
nicht über solche Sachen reden kann.
Wir haben diskutiert, dass ...
Wenn er z.B. mehr zu Hause ist,
bekommt er eine Art Lohn.
Wenn ich das wäre,
bekäme ich einen Lohn.
Das ergibt am meisten Sinn.
Zudem wollen wir beide in die
Säule 3a einzahlen, so gut es geht.
Das haben wir diskutiert,
und das ist auch unser Plan.
Das letzte Jahr ging ich in Pension.
Jetzt bin ich an dem Punkt,
an dem ich mit 77 %
von vorhin leben muss.
Und glaubt mir,
alle jüngeren Frauen:
Das ist einschneidend.
Das glaubt man vorher nicht,
bis es da ist.
Das ist absolut spannend. Danke
vielmals, dass du das geteilt hast.
Alles, was ich gelesen habe -
über Teilzeit, Frauensachen
und wenig Arbeiten -
glaubt mir, es stimmt!
Es stimmt. Ich kenne
ganz viele Frauen in meinem Alter,
die jetzt
in die Altersarmut geraten,
auch mit anständigen Jobs,
weil sie zu lange nicht gearbeitet
und für sich vorgesorgt haben.
Ruth Hofmann (65),
welche die Jungen im Webinar
eindringlich vor Altersarmut warnt,
ist verheiratet
und hat immer voll gearbeitet.
Sie gehört zu einer Generation,
in der
Selbstbestimmung schon möglich war.
Warum haben trotzdem so viele Frauen
in ihrem Alter Geldprobleme?
Ich kam in diese bewegte Zeit
von Wohngemeinschaften,
Hippiezeit und freier Liebe.
Wir hatten endlich die Antibabypille
und wollten ausprobieren.
In den Wohngemeinschaften
konnte man günstig wohnen.
Man fing vielleicht noch eine
Ausbildung an oder wurde Künstlerin.
Und das war
so viel Kraft und Bewegung.
Aber das Geld war nie ein Thema,
niemand dachte daran,
was 40 Jahre später
dann sein könnte.
Ruth Hofmann will die Schuld auf
keinen Fall den Männern zuschieben.
Sie sagt aber klar:
Im Gegensatz zu den Frauen rächt es
sich bei den Männern viel weniger,
wenn sie sich
nicht um ihr Geld kümmern.
Ich meine
wirklich tolle, gute Männer,
die vielleicht das Budget
in den Händen haben,
die Steuererklärung ausfüllen
und es gut meinen.
Diese Männer sind nicht über
das Alter einer Frau informiert.
Sie gehen davon aus:
"Ich sorge ja für meine Familie."
Ich rede wirklich von guten Männern.
"Das wird schon gut."
Nur hat heute
niemand mehr die Garantie,
dass man
wirklich zusammen ins Alter geht,
unter
partnerschaftlich guten Bedingungen.
Erst dann kommt es zum Vorschein.
Ohne böse Absicht
kommt zum Vorschein,
dass die Frau
schlechter gestellt ist.
Ja, vielen Dank für all diese Voten
und diesen offenen Austausch.
Das ist natürlich wunderschön.
Einen schönen Abend!
Was müsste denn politisch geschehen,
damit die Frauen finanziell
nicht mehr schlechter gestellt sind?
Eine schwierige Frage. Ich glaube,
es geht um Individualbesteuerung.
Ich glaube auch,
dass wir Anreizsysteme brauchen,
um dieses ganze Alterssystem
zu reformieren,
also ohne in die Tiefe zu gehen.
Davon würden
ja auch die Frauen profitieren.
Eine Zukunft hat es so nicht -
die Frauen seien mal dahingestellt.
Auch die jungen Leute glauben
ja nicht mehr ans Vorsorgesystem.
Darum legen ja immer mehr Leute
privat Geld an, wenn sie können.
Aber
das kann ja nicht die Zukunft sein.
Darum braucht es
eine radikale Reform.
Und ich glaube auch,
es braucht eine Erleichterung
in den Berufswiedereinstieg,
v.a. für ältere Frauen.
Das wäre sehr willkommen, damit sie
ein Einkommen erwirtschaften können,
wenn sie älter sind
und Kinder bekommen haben.
* Ruhige Musik *
Claudia D. hat es geschafft,
wieder auf die Beine zu kommen.
Sie arbeitet
mittlerweile wieder 60 bis 70 %
und würde heute
einiges anders machen.
Ich hätte vielleicht
weniger damit aufgehört zu arbeiten.
Ich wäre eher im Beruf geblieben.
Ich hätte vielleicht
auch von ihm mehr eingefordert.
Also dass er auch mehr Verantwortung
für die Familie übernimmt.
Ich bin jedoch froh,
dass ich diesen Schritt gemacht
und mehr zu arbeiten begonnen habe,
als ich wusste,
dass es zur Trennung kommen würde.
Sonst wäre es von der Belastung her
noch viel grösser gewesen.
Jetzt, mit 49, sieht es
im Hinblick auf ihre Pensionierung
alles andere als rosig aus.
Wenn ich meinen Altersvorsorgeauszug
anschaue, ist es sehr wenig Geld.
Ich glaube,
es sind 1'800 bis 2'000 Fr.
So gesehen
muss ich sicher darauf achten,
dass ich
da noch etwas Polster anlegen kann.
Zu den Frauen, die in ETFs
oder Bitcoins investieren würden,
wird sie aber auch in Zukunft
wohl nicht gehören.
* Ruhige Musik *
Corinne Brecher hat vor acht Wochen
ihr zweites Kind bekommen
und bereitet
ihren Wiedereinstieg vor.
Hallo, Corinne.
- Hallo.
Darf ich nach hinten?
- Ja, gerne.
Ist es frei?
- Ja.
In einem Co-Working-Space
hat sie genügend Ruhe und Distanz
vom Familienalltag.
Ich bereite die Zeit vor,
in der ich dann wieder voll arbeite.
"Voll" heisst bei mir 60 %,
die ich mir
im Moment vorgenommen habe.
Wenn man eine eigene Firma hat,
kann man nicht 14 Wochen
zu Hause sein und nichts machen.
Es fängt relativ früh
wieder mit E-Mails an,
mit der Social-Media-Präsenz,
vielleicht auch mit dem einen
oder anderen Interview.
Ich habe mir gesagt:
"Ich mache, was ich kann."
"Ich mache es so gut,
wie ich mich fühle."
Das nehme ich an.
Und ... ja. Alles andere - die
Beratung - kommt dann später wieder.
Die Ökonomin gibt schon kurz
nach der Geburt wieder richtig Gas.
Kannst du Frauen verstehen, die
von ihrem Plan abrücken und sagen:
"Nein, ich bleibe
jetzt einfach mal zu Hause"?
Ja,
ich kann es absolut nachvollziehen,
denn ich war auch in dieser Wolke.
Bei mir kam aber
relativ schnell wieder der Wunsch,
zur Arbeit zurückzukehren.
Und wenn dieser Wunsch nicht kommt,
muss ich irgendwo sagen,
dass man auch
in die Selbstverantwortung gehen
und für sich eine neue Organisation
ausarbeiten muss.
Man darf sich
nicht einfach gehen lassen.
Jetzt mache ich Vorbereitungen
für meinen Onlinekurs,
der im Herbst startet.
Das sind Videos, die ich aufnehme.
Herzlich willkommen
zum zweiten Modul!
Wir hatten uns im ersten Modul
die verschiedenen ETFs angeschaut
und auch die verschiedenen Indizes.
Viele Anleger und Anlegerinnen,
v.a. Frauen, sagen,
dass sie Angst um ihr Geld hätten.
Und das ist absolut berechtigt.
Hast du nie ein schlechtes Gewissen,
dass du Frauen sagst,
dass sie investieren sollen,
wenn sie keine Altersvorsorge haben?
Du kannst ja nicht garantieren,
dass sie nachher mehr Geld haben.
Garantieren kannst du es nicht.
Nein.
Aber es ist einfach auch ein Fakt,
dass das Geld
alleine auf dem Konto weniger wird.
Zinsen bekommen wir
heutzutage nicht mehr wirklich.
Das muss man einfach auch sagen.
Inflation ...
Gut, in den Nachbarländern
sind sie schlimmer dran als bei uns.
Ähm ... Aber ...
Es ist einfach ...
Ja, das Geld verliert an Wert.
Und die Frage ist:
Was macht man damit?
An der Börse ist es halt so, dass
man eine relativ gute Chance hat.
Es kommt auch
auf den Anlagehorizont an.
Auch die Banken haben die Frauen als
potenzielle Anlegerinnen entdeckt.
Allerdings spielt sie dabei
auf abgegriffener Klaviatur.
(Originalton) Du investierst
ein Vermögen in deinen Style.
Und deine Säule 3a lässt du liegen?
Zeit für Frankly -
deine Säule-3a-App
mit attraktiven Renditechancen.
So.
Während Corinne arbeitet,
betreut ihr Mann Yanick die Kinder.
Er macht das super. Das weiss ich.
Er muss sich auch daran gewöhnen.
Also ... Das ... äh ...
Wir haben uns gemeinsam
für die Kinder entschieden.
Und ... ähm ... Dann gehört es auch
dazu, dass er seinen Papitag hat,
was ich auch sehr wichtig finde -
damit es nicht zu mamilastig ist.
An der Uni Zürich weist
Helena Trachsel die Studentinnen
auf die Stolpersteine
punkto Vereinbarkeit hin.
Auch wenn viele Studentinnen
gleichberechtigte Modelle wollen:
sie zu leben ist schwieriger,
als man meint.
Die Vereinbarkeit
von Beruf und Privatleben
ist ein Riesenthema in der Schweiz -
wie in keinem unserer Nachbarländer.
Wir haben nicht die gleich
gute Infrastruktur in Childcare,
in Kinderbetreuung -
ab Geburt der Kinder.
Wir haben null Entgelt
für Betreuungsarbeiten.
Diese hängt immer noch
mehrheitlich an den Frauen.
Nicht nur Kinder,
sondern kranke Angehörige.
Ich habe vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
ein Referat gegeben.
Da kamen viele
Public-Affairs-Manager zusammen.
Dann sagte ein Mann zu mir:
"Gleichstellung braucht es nicht."
"Wenn ich mich umsehe, dann
sind diese Frauen gleichgestellt."
Ich sagte: "Wie ist es mit
der unbezahlten Betreuungsarbeit?"
"Da braucht es
doch zwingend Gleichstellung."
Die sahen mich alle an.
Sie waren etwa in meinem Alter.
Ich fragte:
"Wer pflegt denn Ihre Eltern?"
Er sagte: "Logisch,
das macht doch meine Frau."
Ich sagte: "Auch Ihre Eltern?
Sie sind doch auch ein Sohn."
"Ja, klar. Sie konnte
von meinen Eltern profitieren,
als die Kinder klein waren.
Jetzt gibt sie etwas zurück."
Also diese Selbstverständlichkeit,
über uns Frauen zu verfügen,
dass wir
noch etwas zurückzahlen müssen!
Aber nicht nur Männer
denken in alten Mustern.
Auch Frauen
haben ihre Bilder im Kopf.
Ich glaube, dass es in fast allen
Frauen ganz fest verankert ist,
dass Muttersein damit gekoppelt ist,
nicht Karrierefrau sein zu können.
Und man fühlt sich immer schuldig,
wenn man es will
und es beim Partner verlangen
und sagen muss:
"Aber du musst mithelfen,
und zwar mehr als nur 20 %!"
"Ich will, dass du
wirklich drei Tage arbeitest
und zwei Tage zu Hause bist."
"Versuche das mal
an deinem Arbeitsplatz."
Das zu verlangen,
heisst ja zu sagen:
"Die Mutterrolle alleine
genügt mir nicht."
Dass man das nicht aushält,
dass man das von einer Person denkt,
geht den Frauen ab.
"Er liebt mich dann nicht mehr."
"Eine wird nachgeben,
und dann verlässt er mich."
All diese Ängste sind vordergründig
da, dass man es nicht macht.
In den Beratungen - und
wir machen sehr viele Beratungen -
ist immer noch das gängige Muster:
Die Frauen sagen am Arbeitsplatz
Nein und nicht zu Hause.
Und die Männer sagen zu Hause Nein
und nicht am Arbeitsplatz.
Dann haben wir es schon verteilt:
Sie macht zu Hause alles
und er im Geschäft.
Ich glaube auch -
das muss ich auch ehrlich sagen -,
dass Frauen
diesen Ausweg auch mögen,
dass sie eine Wahl haben.
Sie fixieren aber bei den Männern,
dass diese keine Wahl haben
zwischen Berufs- und Privatleben,
weil sie für sich sagen:
"Der Job gefällt mir nicht.
Dort will ich auch nicht arbeiten."
"Dann habe ich halt
zu Hause mehr Kapazität."
"Das tut den Kindern auch gut."
D.h., er muss dann
in diesem Ernährersystem bleiben.
Aber wir sind immer noch
in dieser Rollenzuteilung:
Frau und Mutterschaft gleich
Betreuung und weniger arbeiten.
Der Mann wird Vater: Dann muss er
Gas geben und die Familie ernähren.
Claudia D. ist wie viele andere
auch in diese Rolle gerutscht.
Nun endlich,
nach achteinhalb schwierigen Jahren,
ist die Scheidung durch.
Sie ist erleichtert.
* Ruhige Musik *
Es sieht gut aus.
Auch mit der Unterstützung,
welche die Kinder bekommen -
der Unterhalt der Kinder.
Bei mir muss er nicht mehr so
lange zahlen. Das ist für mich okay.
Ich bin dann
langfristig autonom unterwegs
und muss mich nicht rechtfertigen.
Claudia D. hat sich vorgenommen,
eins nach dem anderen anzugehen.
Um ihre Altersvorsorge
kann sie sich erst kümmern,
wenn sie die Schulden abbezahlt hat.
Ich hätte im Moment gerne
genug Geld, um alles zu zahlen.
Aber mein Ziel ist es,
glücklich und zufrieden zu sein.
Zufriedenheit - das ist das,
was er mir nie nehmen konnte.
Hallo.
Hallo, lieber Schatz.
- Essen.
Oh, isst du gerade?
Noch mehr?
Ja.
Corinne und Yanick Brecher
geben sich Mühe,
nicht in die gängigen Muster
zu fallen.
Doch mit Yanicks Job als Goalie
ist das gar nicht so einfach.
Er kann keinen fixen Tag übernehmen,
um Louisa und Maurice zu betreuen.
Fussball spielen!
Es ist halt einfach unregelmässig.
Es ist meistens anfangs Woche,
dann,
wenn sie normalerweise
bei meinen Eltern
oder bei den Schwiegereltern ist.
Aber dann behalte ich sie meistens
bei mir und geniesse den Tag.
Aber es ist klar:
Die Tage, an denen sie arbeitet,
sind durch die Familie abgedeckt
oder werden es
durch die Krippe sein.
Wenn es sich
unter der Woche spontan ergibt,
dass sie etwas erledigen muss und
ich einen freien Nachmittag habe,
haben wir das flexibel anfangs Woche
so geplant, wie es möglich ist.
Ja.
So gesehen sind wir sehr glücklich,
dass wir durch die Grosseltern
eine solch starke Betreuung haben.
Ich habe natürlich auch
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Diese Arbeit
ist ja auch nicht bezahlt.
Ich habe eben gelesen:
Es sind 8 Mrd. Fr. pro Jahr,
die an Familienarbeit durch
die Grosseltern abgedeckt werden.
Diese Arbeit müsste eigentlich
bezahlt sein, ist es aber nicht.
Jetzt sind wir bald fertig.
Bei den anderen Familien
in ihrem Bekanntenkreis
leben die meisten bereits
neue Familien- und Finanzmodelle.
Von meinen Berufskollegen
kann ich wirklich sagen:
Ich kenne keinen,
der eine klassische Spielerfrau hat,
die zu Hause einfach wartet,
bis er vom Training zurückkommt.
Das gibt es nicht.
Es gibt auch wirklich viele Frauen,
die beruflich ziemlich weit sind.
Und ich glaube, in der Schweiz
ist eher so der Gedanke:
Fussball spielt man bis etwa 35.
Und dann weiss niemand genau,
was passiert.
Bis dahin verdienen wir wahr-
scheinlich anständig und sehr gut.
Das stimmt.
Nachher weiss aber niemand,
wie die zweite Karriere startet.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass Corinne
jetzt von mir profitieren kann,
aber ich werde nach meiner Karriere
in jedem Fall
von ihr profitieren müssen.
Gehst du es holen?
- Ja. Ja.
Vielleicht ist das alles
auch eine Generationenfrage -
hoffentlich.
Corinne jedenfalls möchte
nicht nur für sich eine gute Lösung.
Es ist ihr eine Herzensangelegenheit,
dass alle Paare anfangen,
über ihre Finanzen zu reden.
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es mehr
eine gemeinsame Sache ist,
ein gemeinsames Projekt,
dass man öfter über Geld redet -
selbstverständlicher -
und dass es kein Tabuthema mehr ist.
Das ist es nämlich nicht.
Es braucht einen Dialog
und dass man es gemeinsam angeht.
Beide
lernen nämlich ganz viel dabei.
* Ruhige Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022